i was talking about like some of my  favorite moments from charlie's  boarding lucy's plane to tokyo with tom  green in tow  um you duck taping up the girls in the  racing suit  um i love when you were the you know  what do you guys like what's what is one  of your favorite memories  well some of it's not on film for me  it's  was like i had joined you guys you're  already in training  and you know you guys were so welcoming  i came in you guys  gave me huge hugs and then we started  training and you're like you're doing so  great you're doing so great and i felt  like i'm doing really great  and then the next day i could not move i  was immobilized  i was so flexible the first day and then  i literally i couldn't even bend over i  was like i'm in so much pain and then we  used to do acupuncture and  i mean it was a matter of survival just  getting through that training session  [Music]  you